Die Ligatour Europa ist zurück. Wir blicken heute nach Spanien, England, Italien und Frankreich und das tun wir mit Chris McCarthy, Fabian Pakulat, Christian Bernhardt und Jakob Haffke. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich habe die Ligatur-Runde hier. Die kennt ihr wohl hoffentlich schon und wenn nicht, dann werfe ich euch das langsam vor, denn die muss man kennen. Also schön, Jungs, dass ihr alle da seid. Schönen guten Morgen.
Viel zu lang gedauert.
Ja, viel zu lang. Der hat auch bei uns in der 2. Liga gekickt und der hat davor in Mallorca gekickt, in Saragossa gekickt. Der kommt aus der Jugend von Real Madrid und hat nie den Durchbruch geschafft und hat eigentlich unfassbare Spielanlagen. Ein Tripler, ein Ballstreichler, unwahrscheinlich gute Pässe, Zug nach vorne, kommt oft zum Abschluss, hat aber wahrscheinlich einen miserablen Expected Goal zu welchem gehabt. Hat auf jeden Fall nie den Durchbruch geschafft. Ist immer so zwischen dem Erstligisten, Zweitligisten hin und her getinkt, auch beim FC Malaga. War er zwar Stammspieler, aber hat es auch nicht geschafft, dann wirklich mal Spiele zu entscheiden, obwohl er sich immer wieder ins letzte Drittel vorgetribbelt hat, gute Assists gemacht hat, aber selber im Abschluss eben schwach war. Und der blüht gerade richtig auf, der ist jetzt schon 29, also den hat Zarabiya nochmal richtig gut hinbekommen, hat gegen Real Madrid auch das 1-0 gemacht, ist im Mittelfeld angekommen, sag ich jetzt mal, bei Elche. Und für den freut es mich natürlich ganz besonders, dass der so durchgeschlagen hat. Und es macht einfach Spaß, wie gesagt, Elche anzugucken. Sie finanzieren sich sehr gut, sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch in der zweiten Liga ihre besten Spieler verkaufen müssen. Einer ist, glaube ich, noch in New York gegangen, einer nach Mexiko. Haben aber wieder gut reinvestiert und haben auch einen jungen Spanier, einen 20-jährigen Mendoza heißt der, ein Mittelfeldspieler, da ist angeblich Arsenal dran. Also bei Elche läuft gerade vieles richtig. Gutes sportliches Projekt, tolle Stadion, klappt knapp 40.000, Fußballarena, gehört in die Provinz Valencia mit rein, auf dem Schirm haben, da könnte was gehen die nächsten Jahre.
Ja, und vor allem schön, wir haben Anfang Oktober schon mal über Elche gesprochen, da haben wir vor allem über Sarabia gesprochen und eben aus welcher Trainerschule er kommt. Damals war Elche fünfter und wir sehen, es ist jetzt zwar nicht mehr der fünfte Platz, aktuell der zehnte, aber so arg viel schlechter ist es nicht geworden. Also scheint wirklich nachhaltig zu sein und das ist doch schön zu sehen. Und gleichzeitig hast du uns mit dem Stichwort Arsenal auch schon die perfekte Überleitung zu Chris gebaut, denn wir wollen auch noch mal über den FC Arsenal sprechen. Wir haben das 3 zu 1 gegen Bayern mitbekommen, wir wussten aber schon vorher, dass Arsenal gut ist. Unter anderem weißt du, wie oft Chris, ich eigentlich die Statistik von dir im Gespräch mit anderen nochmal zitiert habe, dass Arsenal im Oktober so wenige Torschüsse nur gegen sich zugelassen hat. Und niemand konnte das glauben. Also danke für diesen Fun-Fact, damit sind aber die Stakes jetzt hoch. Du musst jetzt fast wieder was liefern. Also wie läuft es bei Arsenal, wenn wir auch mal Champions League haben, wahrscheinlich jetzt alle mitbekommen. Aber wenn wir auch mal darüber hinausblicken, denn die anderen, die stolpern ja alle, City, Liverpool und so weiter.
Ja, genau. Und anders als in den letzten Jahren nutzt Arsenal das auch einfach aus. Sie haben selbst eine ziemliche Verletzungskrise momentan. Es fehlen die ersten drei Stürmer. Es fehlt Martinelli, kam jetzt zurück, Madrige, Wöhringart, Gabriel, also einiges dabei. Und trotzdem merkt man es der Mannschaft aktuell nicht an. Und das ist auch einfach aufgrund dieser enormen Tiefe, die dieser Kader hat. Das haben wir ja schon vor kurzem schon angesprochen. Und auch einer der Gründe, warum es jetzt besser läuft und nicht mehr so standardlastig ist, ist Eberhecci Ezi, der im Sommer gekommen ist und jetzt allmählich aufblüht. Und ja, am Sonntag im Derby gegen Tottenham. Das war schon fast kitschig, muss man dazu sagen, was Eberhecci Ezi und Arsenal da lebten. Zunächst gab es für englische Verhältnisse zumindest eine ziemlich sehenswerte Choreo. Dann wurde der Erzrivale mit 4-1 abgeschossen und eben auch die Tabellenführung auf sechs Zähler ausgebaut. Und dann auch noch der Hat-Trick für Ezi. Und das Besondere daran ist, dass Eberhecci Ezi ein Kindheits-Arsenal-Fan ist, wurde mit 13 aus der Academy herausgeschmissen übertrieben, aber nicht weiter berücksichtigt. Musste dann über Millwall, QPR und Palace seinen Weg machen. Und im Sommer war er jetzt bereit für den nächsten Schritt. Tottenham galt als sehr interessiert. Man war sich auch schon einig mit Crystal Palace. Und das hat mittlerweile Ateta auch bestätigt. Daraufhin rief Eberhecci Ezi bei Ateta an und hat gefragt, seid ihr nicht auch interessiert? Und dann hat Ateta eine Vorstandssitzung einberufen. Und man hat sich entschieden, Eberhecci Ezi doch zu verpflichten. Und innerhalb von 24 Stunden war das Ding durch.
Das hat er ja gar nicht mitbekommen. Das ist ja völlig irre. Ich wusste natürlich, dass er Jugend-Arsen-Fan ist und so weiter. Und die drei Tore habe ich mitbekommen. Und die Choreo, noch in kleineren Anführungszeichen, aber du hast es ja schon richtig eingeordnet. Das ist ja tatsächlich witzig, dass er Ateta angerufen hat. Und Ateta kann ja sein Glück auch nicht fassen, weil der konnte ja noch nicht ahnen, wie viele Spieler sich verletzen würden und wie wichtig das wäre, dass du gerade jemanden hast, der richtig trifft.
Genau. Also ich glaube auch, dass da vielleicht auch die Verletzung von Keharvets eine Rolle spielte, weil kurz zuvor hat er sich verletzt und ist jetzt auch länger ausgefallen. Und vielleicht hätte man jetzt nicht Ezi verpflichtet, wenn Harvets nicht so lange ausgefallen wäre. Aber es ist nun mal passiert. Und ja, es war schon eine große Sache für Arsene und für Ezi, dass die beiden jetzt wieder zueinander gefunden haben. Die Fans waren begeistert. Für sie war es einer der größten Transfers der letzten Jahre. Und er tat sich am Anfang ein bisschen schwer. Er ist an sich ein sehr emotionaler, zurückhaltender Typ an sich. Und man merkte so, vielleicht ist das Ganze erst mal ein bisschen überwältigend. Und jetzt gegen Tottenham ist der Knoten dann endgültig geplatzt. Ein Hedwig geschossen zum ersten Mal im Northlanden-Darby. Gab es ein Hedwig seit 1978. Und die Tore waren alle recht ähnlich. Die waren so aus knapp 16 Metern, bei denen er nicht mal jäkig schießt, sondern eher, dass dem Ball ins Tor passt. Das finde ich immer so eine Qualität, wenn man sieht, jemand hält nicht voll drauf, sondern er weiß ganz genau, wo er hinsieht und passt dem Ball dann ins Tor. Und man sieht an diesem Spiel abangesehen, dass Essi Asen eine neue Komponente gibt. Denn wir wissen, dass Atetta ein sehr detailversessener Trainer ist, wo alles so seine Strukturen hat. Jeder hat so seine gewisse Rolle. Und Essi ist so ein Spieler, der da ein bisschen herausbricht und so einen Kreativfaktor mitbringt, einen X-Faktor mitbringt und auch mal das tut, was keiner erwartet und losgelöst von seinen Aufgaben sein Instinkt einfach walten lässt. Und ja, man merkt jetzt, dass mit ihm so eine neue neue Kompetente ins Spiel kommt und die Offensive jetzt auch allmählich ein bisschen mehr fließt und trotzdem ist er einfach auch ein sehr defensiv starker Spieler. Das habe ich gegen Tottenham gesehen und das war wieder so eine kleine Erinnerung. Ich musste irgendwie dran denken, als Atetta kam wurde ja Özil aussortiert. Und die sind ja, was Offensivfußball angeht, nicht unähnlich, sage ich mal, nicht jetzt von der Abschlussstärke, aber beide sehr lässig, arrogant, elegante Spieler. Aber im Gegensatz zu Özil arbeitet Esi auch viel nach hinten mit und das ist halt ein Faktor, den Atetta braucht. Wenn du das nicht tust, spielst du nicht. Und dementsprechend funktioniert das Ganze auch gerade so. Auch gestern gegen Bayern, einen tollen Assist gehabt zum 3 zu 1. Also Esi ist jetzt langsam auch angekommen.
Und zeigt ja auch, wie lange Atetta jetzt einfach schon bei Arsenal ist. Bin nur mal kurz zusammengezückt. Ah ja, richtig, stimmt. Genau. Und damals kann sich lohnen, an einem Trainer festzuhalten. Und falls ihr euch gefragt habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie sieht es denn, wie lief denn jetzt der November? Also ein Spiel gibt es noch gegen Chelsea. Das ist auch definitiv jetzt interessant. Nummer eins gegen Nummer zwei jetzt am Sonntagnachmittag. Also 17.30 können wir quasi das Topspiel Premier League angucken und 20.45 Topspiel Serie A. Und wenn ihr euch gefragt habt, wir wissen ja, wie viele Schüsse man im Oktober zugelassen hat. Wie viele wurden es denn jetzt im November? Man braucht zwei Hände, um es zu sagen. Aber es waren acht Schüsse, die Arsene zugelassen hat. In den Spielen gegen Burnley, Slavia Prag, Sunderland, Tottenham und jetzt eben die Bayern. Übrigens Slavia Prag und Bayern jeweils drei Schüsse. Also auf Augenhöhe haben sich die Bayern da präsentiert. Es ist einfach weiter absolut faszinierend. Letzte Frage dazu. So ein bisschen jetzt musst du in die Glaskugel gucken. Aber zieht es Arsene durch? Holen sie den Titel?
Ich glaube ja. Ich glaube, es liegt an zwei Gründen, mache ich das fest. Zum einen Liverpool haben wir darüber gesprochen. Die werden nicht mehr in den Titelkampf finden. Man City ist, was die Qualität des Kaders angeht, nach dem Umbruch auch noch nicht da. Das merkt man. Da kannst du nicht mehr so gut rotieren. Die werden noch weiter Punkte lassen. Chelsea bleibt jetzt abzuwarten. Inwiefern sie das Level halten können, das war immer so das Problem der letzten Jahre. Aber was für Arsene spricht, ist diese absurde Tiefe. Die können jeden Ausfall kompensieren. Gabriel fehlt, Hinkapier macht das, Mosquera macht das. Wenn das so weiter läuft und sie nicht zu sehr von den Verletzungen heimgesucht werden, glaube ich nicht, dass sie großartig nachlassen werden.
Arsene hatte in allen Pflichtspielen in dieser Saison, das müssten 13 gewesen sein, nee, müssten sogar mehr gewesen sein, auf jeden 19 Spiele sind es. Und man hat nur in einem Spiel einen Expected-Goals-Ergänzwert von größer als einem Tor zugelassen. Und das war im allerersten Pflichtspiel diese Saison. Also, wir reden viel über Offensive über Arsene. Lasst die Defensive nicht vergessen. Es ist einfach, es ist fantastisch. Also Arsene thront gerade über der Premier League. Wir haben auch schon Christian über denjenigen gesprochen, der über der Serie A thront. Es gibt aber durchaus noch andere Teams, die da überraschend oben mitmischen. Und über ein solches möchtest du uns noch ein bisschen was erzählen.
Ja, über Bologna und ich glaube, das überraschend muss man streichen, weil das ist halt nicht mehr überraschend, weil die das jetzt schon zum wiederholten Male machen. Also ganz kurz sind auch nur drei Punkte hinter der Tabellenspitze. Es sind fünfter, vierter Punkt gleich mit Inter. Und ja, Vincenzo Italiano hatten wir hier ja auch schon ein, zwei Mal. Also wirklich herausragend, was die weiterhin machen. Bologna spielt hohen Rhythmus, hohe Intensität, hohes Pressing. Ich hatte es ja vorhin mit dem PPDA. Roma ist auf Platz 2 in der Serie A. Bologna ist auf Platz 3, lässt nur 8,5 Pässe zu. Dann gehen die rein, weil die intensiv und mit hohen Pressing spielen. Und sie haben jetzt eine unfassbare, gute Balance gefunden. Denn, vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch, wir haben über Italiano auch gesprochen. Er war ja bei der Fiorentina. Die Fiorentina hat damals zwei Mal ins Conference League Finale geführt, auch ins Coppa Italia Finale. Die haben sie alle verloren, weil es da manchmal defensiv noch ein bisschen naiv war. Das war dann dieses hohe Verteidigen, diesen Durchschieben, war dann in so manchen Momenten, da gab es gerade in den Finals gegen West Ham, glaube ich, war das eine Finale, wo sie dann bei 1-1 in der 88. in der Mittellinie verteidigen und West Ham kommt durch und macht das 2-1. So, und das, da hat sich Italiano extrem weiterentwickelt. Also Bologna verteidigt nicht mehr so naiv. Sie haben jetzt auch die drittbeste Abwehr der Liga. Also, obwohl sie hochpressen, obwohl sie lücken lassen, ist es viel balanciert. Kleiner Fun-Fact auch zum PPDA. Auf Platz 1, wer es schätzt hier, steht in Italien. Also Roma auf 2, Bologna auf 3.
Ich habe vorhin schon gedacht, es müsste, ist es Napoli? Das wäre jetzt mein erster.
Nein, nein, nein.
Inter?
Nein.
Milan.
Nein. Milan ist auf Platz 20. Milan ist letzter in Pressing-Intensität. Ja, das ist das typische Allegri halt. Tief stehen, tiefer Block, daneben umschalten. Es ist Como von Fabregas. Fabregas Como läuft extrem hoch an. Und jetzt kommt der Fact dazu, diese drei Mannschaften, also Como, Bologna und die Roma, sind auch die drei Mannschaften mit der besten, mit den besten Abwehren, statistisch. Also Pressing kann sich auch defensiv auszahlen. Nur nur so viel dazu, kleiner kleiner kleiner Fun-Fact. Ne, Bologna wirklich herausragend, weil einige erinnern sich vielleicht noch, im vorletzten Sommer haben sie Calafiori in Zirkzee verloren. Also zwei Ausnahmespieler haben trotz des letzten Jahres diese sehr gute Saison gespielt, haben ja die Coppa Italia gewonnen und waren in der Champions League auch nach einem Stotter-Start sehr gut drin. Dieses Jahr im Sommer verlieren sie in Deuille an Nottingham und Beukäma an Napoli. Also auch wieder zwei absolute, nicht nur Stammspieler, sondern Stützen und machen trotzdem einfach weiter. Also es ist beeindruckend, was Italien aus dem Kader herausholt. Zweitbester Angriff der Liga eben auch. Also diese hohen Ballgewinne führen ganz oft zu gefährlichen Szenen. Und das vielleicht herausragendste an Bologna ist, also zumindest in Italien gibt es keine Mannschaft, also keine Trainer, der es schafft, den kompletten Kader so gut in sein System zu implementieren, dass er auch trotz vieler Wechsel den Fußball bekommt, den er sich wünscht. Beispiel. Am vorletzten Spieltag in der Serie A hat Bologna gegen Napoli 2-0 gewonnen. Napoli hat keinen Stich gemacht. Also das war wirklich, Bologna war in allen Belangen überlegen. Am Spieltag draus spielt Bologna in Udinese. Und man würde jetzt meinen, die haben Napoli hergespielt. Das hat er seine Stammelf gefunden. Italiano nimmt sechs Wechsel vor. Sechs. Und Bologna gewinnt 3-0 auswärts. Also er schafft es wirklich, den kompletten Kader komplett in seinem System zu integrieren. Deswegen sind die auch gar nicht abhängig von einzelnen Spielern. Klar, Orsolini, Bester Torschütze, Santiago Castro, der Neuner, der Argentinier liefern. Aber das ist ein so tiefer Kader. Der ist logisch nicht so tief wie Arsenal im Sinn von qualitativ. Aber er schafft es, Italiano aus dem Kader alles das rauszuholen, auch von 17, 18, 19, 20 Spielern. Und ich würde sagen, in der heutigen Zeit, mit den fünf Wechseln, mit den vielen Spielen, Bologna nicht zu vergessen, spielt ja auch Europa League, also die spielen unter der Woche ja auch, ist das schon eine Riesenqualität. Wenn du es schaffst, dann den kompletten Kader hinter dir zu vereinen und dann sozusagen auch von vielen Spielern was zu kriegen, die vielleicht am Wochenende davor nicht in der Startelf gestanden sind.
Also Leute, wenn ihr Bologna-Fan seid, nehmt euch ab Ende April nichts mehr vor. Bologna wird dann spielen gegen die Roma, gegen Neapel, gegen Atalanta, gegen Inter. Ach, Juve habe ich noch ignoriert. Also nehmt euch am Mitte April nichts vor. Das ist nämlich direkt das Spiel davor. Christian, wie groß im Prozent ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Bologna vielleicht sogar um den Titel mitspielt?
Schön, dass du es fragst. In Italien gibt es jetzt auch schon ein paar Dinge. Jetzt sind die Fragen aufgekommen, ja, können die vielleicht auch Scudetto? Also ich wäre noch ein bisschen skeptisch. Einfach, sie haben die Doppelperlastung. Klar, sie moderieren das super, aber sie müssen jetzt auch in der Europa-Liga ein paar Punkte liegen lassen. Da müssen sie jetzt erstmal auch wieder ein bisschen reinkommen. Ich glaube, für uns Scudetto ist es ein bisschen zu früh, aber dass die in die Champions League-Plätze mitspielen, auf jeden Fall. Also da muss auch Juve schauen, dass sie an denen dranbleiben, weil die eben, wie gesagt, die Intensität trotz der Doppelbelastung hochhalten, weil sie viele Varianten haben, weil sie nicht abhängig sind von jemandem. Und ja, letzter Satz, also Vicenzo Italiano ist wirklich, da können wir vielleicht auch mal ein großes Thema daraus machen, wenn wir jetzt über Jahre, die letzten Jahre hernehmen, ist für mich mittlerweile Vicenzo Italiano vielleicht der beste italienische Trainer, weil er hat Spezia vor x Jahren, ist mit denen aufgestiegen, hat es in der Liga gehalten, ist nach Florenz gewechselt, hat die Fiorentina zweimal ins Conference League Finale geführt, ins Coppa Italia Finale, kommt nach Bologna, nach Thiago Motta, wo alle dachten, oh, Thiago Motta hat hier das Wunder vollbracht. Und im Prinzip macht Italiano jetzt einfach da weiter, hat letztes Jahr die Coppa Italia gewonnen, das war der erste Titel seit über 50 Jahren, hat mit ihnen Champions League gespielt, ist jetzt wieder vorne mit dabei. Also die Konstanz, die Italiano einfach Jahr für Jahr sozusagen zeigt für dem, was er, also erreicht sozusagen immer seine Ziele mit der Mannschaft, die er gerade hat. Und deswegen ist es für mich nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis der bei einem, sag ich mal, großen Namen ankommt. Aber der Punkt ist ja, er macht ja Bologna mittlerweile auch ligamentär und schon zu einem großen Namen. Also das ist ja auch mit sein Verdienst. Letzter Satz dazu, Milan war ja vor der Saison interessiert, aber Italiano hat gesagt, nee, ich bleibe in Bologna. Mein Weg bei Bologna ist noch nicht zu Ende und das untermauert da in dieser Saison wieder beeindruckend.
Also wenn wir diese Sendung machen, dann müssen wir nämlich auch genau darüber sprechen, warum so heiß begehrte Trainer dann bei ihren Teams bleiben. Denn mit Fabregas bei Como ist es ja ganz genauso.
Genau, dasselbe Spiel. Genau, am vergangenen Wochenende war ja Milan gegen Inter, das große Derby in Mailand. Und das hätte vor der Saison, wenn es nach den Plänen von Milan und Inter gewesen wäre, wäre das nicht Kibo gegen Allegri gewesen, sondern Fabregas gegen Italiano. Weil Inter wollte ja unbedingt Fabregas eben auch. Aber Fabio Barca hat gesagt, ich bleibe bei Como. Como ist eine andere Geschichte, da haben wir schon darüber gesprochen, können wir auch gerne wieder darüber sprechen. Aber Bologna und Italiano, Italiano hat sich da auch ganz klar zu Bologna kommen, mit dem gesagt, nein, nein, wir machen da weiter. Und guter Punkt, Max, das kann man definitiv auch mal aufgreifen, um zu zeigen, wie andere Clubs nachhaltig gut arbeiten und das dann auch schaffen, große, vielleicht talentierte Trainer länger zu behalten, weil sie ein gutes Konzept ausgearbeitet haben.
Ich weiß nicht, wann Leipzig gegen Leverkusen gespielt hat oder noch spielt in dieser Saison, aber nach allem, was ich gehört habe, nach den Plänen der Verantwortlichen, wäre das Fabregas gegen Fabregas gewesen auf der Trainerbank.
Ja, die Idee hatten ein paar andere auch mit Fabregas.
Also der ist wirklich sehr hoch im Kurs. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie oft ich den gehört habe, wenn ich mal jemanden gefragt habe, wen würdet ihr denn jetzt verpflichten von Tränen für euer Team?
Ohne da jetzt irgendwie, Chris weiß da logischerweise mehr, aber falls irgendwann mal bei Arsenal die Erdthetära zu Ende gehen sollte, was wahrscheinlich noch lange dauern wird, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass bei Arsenal auch der eine oder andere Gedanke an Herrn Fabregas gerichtet werden würde.
Soweit sind sie ja gar nicht auseinander vom Alter.
Ja, ja, eben, genau. Also es ist ja gar kein Thema bei Arsenal, aber ich sage nur logisch, denn den Ruf, den sich Fabregas schon erarbeitet hat, der ist nicht das Schlechteste.
Okay, aber ich wollte gar nicht so sehr von Bologna wegführen, aber danke für diesen Sneak Peek, weil wir haben sie ja zuletzt, wenn man es mitbekommen hat, dann gegen Freiburg gesehen und da hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht, dass es so positiv gerade läuft, gut ein Update zu bekommen. Und wenn wir bei talentierten Trainern sind, die mit kleineren Mitteln Erfolg verschaffen, Jakob, dann frage ich mich, ist Alexandre Dujoe dann auch so ein heißes Träneisen? Denn der ist bei Angé der Übungsleiter, wie man so schön sagt, und bei denen läuft es nämlich auch sehr gut.
Ja, bei denen läuft es gut. Ich würde aber jetzt nicht Alexandre Dujoe auf eine Stufe mit Vincenzo Italiano stellen wollen. Ich glaube nicht, dass Dujoe in Zukunft bei einem wirklich größeren Verein zu sehen sein wird. Es ist eher eine Sache, die bei Angé auffällt, dass sie sehr große, ja, wenig Fluktuation auf der Trainerposition haben. Also Dujoe ist jetzt auch schon seit Anfang 2023 im Amt. Allgemein hatte Angé seit 2006 nur fünf verschiedene Trainer. Also, ich glaube, da muss man auch, findet man in Europa auch nicht viele Vereine, bei denen das der Fall ist. Und es fliegt aber alles ein bisschen unterm Radar. Also ich glaube auch Angé ist so, wenn man sagt, okay, wir überlegen uns mal die 18 Vereine aus der Liga, dürfte das bei den meisten so mit der letzte Verein sein, auf dem man dann kommt. Obwohl sie jetzt tatsächlich seit 2015, 16 bis auf eine einzige Saison immer in der ersten Liga gespielt haben in Frankreich und auch tatsächlich nur in der Abstiegssaison schlechter als Platz 14 gestanden haben. Also tatsächlich auch häufig so im unteren Mittelfeld gelandet sind und letztendlich stehen sie ja jetzt auch auf Platz 11 im Mittelfeld ganz gut da. Und ja, vielleicht zum Vereinshintergrund noch ein bisschen. Es ist ein netter Fakt, dass sie im Stade Raymond Coupar spielen. Also der große Raymond Coupar hat früher, hat seine ersten Profischritte bei Angers gemacht, bevor er dann zu seiner Weltkarriere aufgebrochen ist und ja unter anderem auch einen Ballon d'Or, glaube ich, gewonnen hat. Also da auch eine historische Persönlichkeit. Aber ansonsten ist Angers ein recht kleiner Verein und das ist dann auch der Grund, warum wir jetzt drüber sprechen wollen, dass es durchaus bemerkenswert ist, dass sie auf Platz 11 in der Tabelle stehen. Vor allem, weil sie vor der Saison auch von vielen als einer der heißesten Abstiegskandidaten gehandelt wurden, weil sie mit Esteban Le Paul und Bamba Diemg zwei ihrer drei besten Torschützen der letzten Saison verloren haben. Also Diemg hat fünf Tore gemacht, war aber von Lorient nur ausgeliehen, die ja letzte Saison noch zweite Liga gespielt haben, dann aber aufgestiegen sind, ist jetzt bei Lorient geblieben. Und Le Paul ist ja kurz vor Transfer-Schluss für 13 Millionen ungefähr nach Rennen gewechselt. Ich glaube, da hat David ja auch in der letzten Folge drüber gesprochen, meine ich zumindest, dass er ihn da auch erwähnt hat. Und performt daher jetzt auch ganz gut, hat letzte Saison 13 Tore geschossen von insgesamt auch nur 32 Toren. Also da ein Drittel oder sogar deutlich mehr als ein Drittel der Tore erzielt. Und da war dann die Prognose durchaus naheliegend, dass es bei Anjel wirklich nur gegen den Abstieg geht. Ich will sie jetzt auch nicht da komplett rausnehmen aus dem Abstiegskampf. Es sind auch nur fünf Punkte auf Platz 16, der ja auch in Frankreich die Relegation bedeuten würde. Und vor allem, wir hatten vorhin bei Bernie schon über die Überperformance von Miles Vila gesprochen. Und einen solchen Fall gibt es auf jeden Fall auch bei Anjel. Denn die haben im Tor Ervel Kofi, einen 29-Jährigen, den Nationaltorhüter Burkina Fasos, der von Lens ausgeliehen ist, hat eigentlich noch keine große Erfahrung in der Ligue 1. Und der spielt wirklich bisher eine überragende Saison. Der hat acht, mehr als acht Tore nach Expected Goals und Target Prevented. Also ist da maßgeblich für eine dann doch recht große Überperformance von Angers verantwortlich. Sie hätten eigentlich so 24 Tore kassieren sollen. Nach Expected Goals und Against sind jetzt bei 15, was dann im Umkehrschluss die viertbeste Abwehr der Liga ist. Da stellt sich dann natürlich aber definitiv die Frage, ob das über die Saison aufrechterhalten werden kann. Sie haben auch– Kofi hat auch schon zwei von drei Elfmetern gehalten. Also vielleicht ist das jetzt auch ein Zwischenhoch. Und diese gute Abwehr muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass es sich durch die ganze Saison zieht. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert. Und er spielt auch wirklich eine überragende Saison. Also in ganz vielen Spielen ist er dann der, der Angers wirklich rettet. Jetzt am Wochenende hat man 1-0 in Toulouse gewonnen. Da hat Toulouse auch noch dreimal Aluminium getroffen. Und Kofi hat auch noch ein paar Bälle richtig gut rausgeholt. Also läuft ganz gut bisher bei ihm.
Aber eben, wie gesagt, nur geliehen ist es nur ein Kofi to go. Also er wird– Entschuldigung, ich musste ihn machen. Ich habe aber trotzdem noch eine kurze Rückfrage zu Angers. Denn wenn ich mir hier angucke, wie so die Transferbilanz der letzten Jahre aussieht, da ist es wirklich auffallend, wie viele Spiele Angers hochzieht aus dem eigenen zweiten Team. Und in dieser Saison, vor dieser Saison, war es ja besonders drastisch. Man hat eben nur Kofi und Mouton, der bisher auch eine ganz okaye Rolle spielt, so nach seiner Einseitszeit, gemessen. Die hat man beide verpflichtet. Ansonsten eben Abgänge gehabt. Auch Routonji ja unter anderem zu St. Pauli. Brauche ich die ja nicht erzählen. Grüße an den Flugkopfball an der Stelle. Aber wenn ich jetzt mal einen meiner berühmten Bundesligavergleiche mache, ist Angers quasi der SC Freiburg der französischen Liga. Dass man eben vor allem aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs die Spieler hochzieht und so in der Liga bleibt?
Ich habe da auch darüber nachgedacht, ob man den Vergleich gut machen kann. Zuerst aber einmal Untonji, das ist nur sein Bruder. Das ist nicht der, der jetzt bei St. Pauli spielt. Ah, das stimmt.
Satriko Untonji, ja, da hätte ich mal besser gelesen. Ja, lustig. Ich dachte mir noch, warum ich das nicht wusste. Okay, deswegen.
Aber ansonsten ist es wirklich bemerkenswert. Also ich habe auch mal nachgezählt, es sind jetzt 11 Spieler im Kader, also die bei Transfermarkt im Kader stehen. Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen schwammig, je nachdem, die aus der eigenen Jugend stammen. Und das ist schon echt bemerkenswert, gerade wenn man halt nicht so ein großer Verein ist. Und ich glaube, wenn man jetzt an französische Talentschmieden denkt, ist auch Angers auch da nicht der erste Name, der einem einfällt. Und gerade in der Offensive ist es halt bemerkenswert. Also wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen, dass sie ihre zwei besten Stürmer eigentlich verloren haben. Der andere, der letzte Saison noch mehr Tore geschossen hat, ist Imad Abdelhi im Mittelfeld, der jetzt auch noch da ist. Der hatte sechs Tore gemacht in der letzten Saison. Jetzt in dieser Saison erst ein Tor. Und aber zwei Namen sind da durchaus zu nennen, die auch beide jetzt aus dem B-Team gekommen sind im Sommer mit Ziddiqi Scherief und Prosper Peter. Mit dem wunderschönen Namen auf jeden Fall. Die sind beide erst 18, haben jetzt beide auch jeweils schon drei Tore gemacht. Und das, obwohl sie auch schon einige Spiele mal verletzt verpasst haben. Also jetzt auch noch nicht so sonderlich viele Minuten gesammelt haben. Die aber durchaus Potenzial haben. Und das ist halt wirklich bemerkenswert, dass es dann so ein kleiner Verein da schafft, so einen Abgang zumindest bisher aufzufangen, mit zwei wirklich ja komplett unerfahrenen Spielern, die aber jetzt in der Liga 1 durchaus zeigen, dass sie auch schon mithalten können und ja mit 18 auch noch ganz schön viel Luft nach oben haben im Normalfall.
Aber wirklich und also Award für den schönsten Namen dieser Sendung geht auf jeden Fall an Prosper Peter. Das muss man sagen. Das ist ein ganz fantastischer Name. Also so ist die Situation in Orangé. Wir machen noch einen kurzen Flug über die Ligen. Fabian, was hast du uns denn aus Spanien noch mitgebracht?
Ich habe euch noch Espanyol Barcelona mitgebracht, den anderen Club aus Barcelona, auch ein spanischer Traditionsverein, der momentabellen Sechster ist. Und das ist schon bemerkenswert, denn vor zwei Jahren waren wir noch in der zweiten Liga und gehörten noch einer chinesischen Investorengruppe. In der zweiten Liga wurde der Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft hochgezogen, Manolo González, und der ist nach wie vor Trainer. Der ist sofort mit denen wieder aufgestiegen, hat im ersten Jahr die Liga gehalten und ist jetzt im Moment Sechster, und das überhaupt nicht zu Unrecht in der Primera Division. Und seit Oktober gehört der Verein übrigens nicht mehr den chinesischen Investoren, sondern er gehört zu Alan Poes und dem VeloCity Sports Partners. Dem gehört unter anderem auch Burnley, wie ich recherchiert habe. Und dann die, also wir haben hier wieder kleines Multiclub Ownership. Fantastisch. Das dachte ich doch, dass dich das interessiert, Max.
Habt ihr auch gehört, dass Uli Hoeneß jetzt wieder gesagt hat, 50 plus 1 muss abgeschafft werden, dass so Teams wie Hamburg, der HSV, der VfB und so weiter, dass die richtig geile Investoren kriegen. Man nennt es so. Ja, das wird halt dann der Viertverein für die Investoren. Das wird richtig klasse für den VfB. Viel Erfolg damit. Aber gut.
Ja, aber Espanol macht trotz alledem sehr gute Arbeit, muss ich sagen. Wie gesagt, ist eigentlich der kleine Gruppe aus Katalonien und eigentlich auch so eine Fahrstuhlmannschaft. Sind jetzt aber wie gesagt 6ter, machen das richtig gut und haben einen Trainer, der sich auch nicht scheut, die Liga zu kritisieren wegen Montagspielen, wegen irgendwas. Also normalerweise kuschen die Spanier ja sehr gerne vor der Liga und sagen nichts dagegen. Und das ist einer, der immer wieder sagt, Auslandsspiele finde ich kacke, Montagsspiele finde ich kacke, die Ansetzungen finde ich alle scheiße. Der nimmt kein Blatt vom Mund und das finde ich sehr, sehr sympathisch. Und ich muss natürlich noch einen Stürmer hervorheben. Und zwar ist das Roberto Fernandez Rhein, U21-Nationalspieler Spaniens, der vorher wo gespielt hat.
Ich komme nicht drauf, es hört sich an wie eine Eissorte.
Er kommt vom FC Malaga, er ist hier groß geworden. In der Jugend haben wir den ausgebildet. Er hat uns von der 3. in die 2. Liga wieder geschossen. Und dann ist Sporting Braak aus Portugal auf ihn aufmerksam geworden. Haben ihn uns abgekauft. Und da hat er aber nicht eingeschlagen, ist dann zu Espanyol weiter. Und dort ist er richtig gut unterwegs. Ist zwar nicht immer Stammstürmer, aber macht seine Sache trotzdem ganz gut. Ist jetzt eingewechselt worden, zum Beispiel gegen Sevilla. Hat ein wunderschönes Siegtor geschossen, das 25 Metern. Großer Hühne, blond, was für Spanier jetzt nicht ganz üblich ist, aber der auch wird seinen Weg machen. Und der wird auch, wenn er so weitermacht, bei dem einen oder anderen größeren Verein noch landen. Und dann vielleicht noch ein kleiner Hinweis zu einem englischen Spieler, eine sehr interessante Verpflichtung. Da kamen Ablöse frei von Blackburn. Hatt ich überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm. Tyrus Dolan war mal U20-Nationalspieler. England ist inzwischen 23 und spielt da bei Espanol Stamm und macht richtig Dampf auf dem Flügel. Einfach nur so dachte ich vielleicht, kann Chris da was zu sagen? Ich hatte den überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm. Ich auch nicht. Sehr gut. Und vielleicht ein letzter Hinweis. Christian Riedl ist zu Espanol Barcelona gewechselt von Darmstadt aus der zweiten Liga. Am Ende des Transfer Fensters. Innenverteidiger hat auch sechs Spiele von Anfang an gemacht und durchgespielt. Da kam er ein bisschen näher, ich glaube von 12 oder 13 Spielen. Also völlig überraschend, ist mir auch nicht bewusst gewesen. Und plötzlich sehe ich da so einen deutschen Innenverteidiger bei Espanol. Auch sehr interessant. Er hat gutes Potenzial, war auch ein O21-Nationalspieler schon mal Deutschlands. Und mal gucken, was die noch so machen. Also die haben bei Espanol ein ganz gutes Package zusammen im Moment. Und wie gesagt, sind Tabellen sechs da. Und ja, mal gucken, wie es weitergeht bei denen.
Sehr interessant. Und bei den Expected Goals against liegt Espanol 0,1 vor Barcelona. Also dem großen Barcelone. Es tut mir jetzt fast ein bisschen leid, das so formuliert zu haben. Aber ihr wisst, wie ich es gemeint habe, liebe Hörer.
An denen sie übrigens auch den Torwart verloren haben, der letztes Jahr so richtig stark war. Juan Garcia, der ja jetzt auch sich verletzt hat. Ah gut, Barcelona und Torhüter ist eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Also Espanol haben wir jetzt im Blick. Und natürlich auch Thierrys Adolin, der aus der U19 von Preston zu Blackburn gewechselt ist und davon dann zu Espanol. Also wirklich schockierend, Chris, dass du das nicht auf dem Schirm hast. Dabei war er doch mit 15 noch in der Jugend von City und ist dann zu Preston und dann ist er zu Clitherow und dann– ja gut, okay, ich lasse es. Gut, aber Chris, wenn du noch mit dabei bist, was hast du noch als letztes Premier League-Thema? Du wolltest noch mal über Thierrys Adolin wahrscheinlich sprechen.
Genau, das Thema nicht passt. Ja, ich habe ein kurioses Thema aus der Partie Everton gegen Manchester United und zwar war das in der 13. Minute, da hat Edrissa Gay Michael Keane eine Ohrfalge verpasst und rot gesehen. Und das Kulisse daran ist, die spielen beide in der gleichen Mannschaft. Das war so ein bisschen das Gesprächsthema jetzt die letzten Tage. Die haben sich ein bisschen in die Haare gekriegt nach einer Chance von United. Und daraufhin hat Keane Gay ein bisschen gestummt. Gay hat dann mit einer Ohrfalge reagiert, hat rot gesehen, was auch regeltechnisch konform ist. Ich glaube, das wird in Deutschland ähnlich sein. Aber wenn man eine Tätigkeit macht, ist es eigentlich ganz egal gegen wen. Gerade wenn es Richtung Kopf und Gesicht geht. Aber das Witzige fand ich, zum einen hat Elberten trotzdem gewonnen. Trotz des grünen Platzverweises wurde dadurch zur ersten Mannschaft überhaupt, die zu zehnt in Old Trafford gewinnt. Echt? Ich überhaupt? Ich glaube für mehr die Historie. Wir müssen noch mal nachschauen.
Ja gut, aber trotzdem krass.
Okay, trotzdem, genau. Ebenfalls interessant, es war der erste Sieg für Mois in Old Trafford, seitdem er bei Manchester United als Trainer kläglich gescheitert ist. Und eben Jena Mois fand ich ganz witzig, hat über die rote Karte gesagt, dass er das ziemlich mag, dass seine Spieler kämpfen. Es zeigt, dass sie nicht alles hinnehmen und akzeptieren, wenn jemand nicht 100 Prozent gibt oder etwas falsch macht. Es zeigt, dass sie tapfs sind und diese Mentalität will er vorleben. Die will er in seiner Mannschaft. Das fand ich auch ganz witzig. Aber es ist anscheinend halb so wild. Geij hat sich entschuldigt. Jena hat auch gesagt, dass es aus der Welt ist. Aber das war eine nette Anekdote vom Spieltag.
Und Everton liegt damit eben vor Liverpool in der Termine. Das ist natürlich ganz wichtig. Und Geij hatte aber wahnsinnig Glück, dass das Spiel gerade unterbrochen war. Denn wenn das Spiel noch gelaufen wäre und er gibt seinen Mitspieler im eigenen Strafraum eine Ohrfalge, dann gibt es Rot und Strafstoß. Kleiner Regelfun-Fact. Dafür hört ihr doch den Rasenfunk, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Für Multiclub Ownership schlechte Wortwitze und das. Also, Everton, ein interessantes Wochenende auf jeden Fall kann man so sagen. Bernie, was haben wir denn in der Serie A noch zu besprechen?
Ich bringe euch noch kurz Maurizio Sarri's Lazio mit. Auch ein spannendes Thema, vielleicht zur Einordnung im Sommer. Lazio, aufgrund von wirtschaftlichen Restriktionen, durfte Lazio keinen einzigen Spieler verpflichten. Also Sarri ist zu Lazio gekommen und es wurde dann erst relativ spät im Transferfenster klar, dass gar nichts gemacht werden kann.
Da hat er wahrscheinlich auch ruhig darauf reagiert, so wie wir ihn kennen.
Maurizio Sarri hat die letzten Wochen gesagt, wenn es nicht Lazio gewesen wäre, sein neben Napoli sein Herzensverein, dann wäre er gegangen. Genau, aber da es eben Lazio war, hat er gesagt, komm, jetzt stehen wir jetzt irgendwie durch. Und dementsprechend katastrophal war der Saisonstart. Die haben einiges verloren, aber jetzt eben, und deswegen habe ich sie kurz mitgebracht, in den letzten acht Spielen nur ein einziges verloren gegen Inter. Sie haben in diesen acht Spielen auch mit die meisten Punkte in der Liga geholt, sind jetzt wieder dran, sind dann Juve zum Beispiel dran in der Tabelle, sind wirklich in Sichtweise der europäischen Plätze. Und deswegen, ja, schön, dass Lazio quasi diese Energie aus sich selbst herausgeschöpft hat. Sari und die Spieler verweisen logischerweise seit Saisonbeginn darauf, gut, dann ist das jetzt halt womöglich so diese Wagenburg-Mentalität. Wir sind es, brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht lang drüber heulen, sondern es gibt keine anderen Alternativen, wir müssen es hinkriegen. Und das schaut jetzt echt deutlich besser aus, wie gesagt, sie sind in Flo gekommen, haben jetzt am Wochenende Kaljeri geschlagen, haben Ljube auch geschlagen vor einigen Wochen. Und Provedail hast du schon angesprochen, genau, haben auch eine sehr stabile Defensive. Und das Schöne, deswegen habe ich es mitgebracht, Sari hat jetzt nach diesem Kaljeri-Sieg gemeint, seine Mannschaft hat ihn heute an das Napoli von vor sieben, acht Jahren erinnert. Und das Napoli von vor sieben, acht Jahren war Saris Napoli, das wir vielleicht auch noch ein paar in Erinnerungen haben. Ich sage nur Mertens, Calahon, Insigne. Und allein, dass Sari dieses Gefühl hat, dass die Mannschaft, Lazio, auch so ein bisschen diese Vibes ausstrahlt. Er hat auch gesagt, klar, die ist technisch bei Weitem nicht so stark wie damals sein Napoli, aber halt einfach hat gemeint, wie wir das Spiel aufs Feld bringen, wie wir das Spiel lesen. Er hat Freude daran, hat er gesagt, wir haben alle Freude. Und das ist, finde ich, schön, dass die Ursprungs-Sariball-Mannschaft, nämlich das Napoli von damals, dass allein die Erinnerungen bei ihm geweckt werden, zeigt, dass Lazio auf einem guten Weg ist. Und jetzt am Wochenende fahren sie in San Siro zu Milan. Und wie gesagt, müssen sich da in keinster Weise verstecken, weil sie echt gut den Ansari-Rhythmus wieder gefunden haben. Und das, obwohl zum Beispiel mit Tati Kasseianos oder Rovella zwei ganz, ganz wichtige Spieler schon seit Wochen verletzt fehlen. Also er hat eh nichts vom Transfermarkt bekommen. Dazu fehlen ihm noch Leistungsträger verletzungsbedingt. Und trotzdem hat der Lazio wieder in die Spur gebracht. Maurizio Sarri.
Fünf der letzten sechs Spiele zu Null gespielt, Napoli. Aber du musst mir noch ganz kurz sagen, Bernie, also es gab keine Transfers. Ich sehe hier aber auf transfermarkt.de, sehe ich Transfers für diese Saison. Also Rovella, Tavares, Gigolo, Pellegrini.
Genau, das ist diese typische, das ist leider ein bisschen ein Problem auf Transfermarkt. In Italien ist es ja ganz oft so, da wird ein Spieler im Sommer verpflichtet, erst mal auf Leihbasis.
Ja, okay und dann?
Aber der Punkt ist eben der, es gibt ja noch wirklich, du kannst ja ein Spieler auf Leihbasis verpflichten und dann würde der kommenden Sommer erstmal wieder an den Ausgangsverein zurückgehen und dann muss man halt schauen, wie geht es weiter. In Italien ist aber sehr häufig, dass ein Spieler zwar erst mal auf Leihbasis verpflichtet wird, aber da die Kaufpflicht schon drin ist. Im Prinzip geht es nur darum, die Ausgabe ins nächste Budgetjahr reinzuschieben. Aber es ist in dem Moment schon klar, dass der Spieler fix bei Lazio ist. Deswegen passiert es manchmal bei Transfermarkt, dass man oft bei italienischen Vereinen denkt, die haben im Sommer noch mal vier neue geholt. Aber die haben sie eigentlich schon im Sommer davor geholt, weil das schon damals fest mit der Kaufpflicht verbunden war.
Okay, alles klar. Sehr gut. Ich dachte mir das schon, aber ich wollte eben einmal kurz nachfragen. Dann blicken wir nochmal nach Frankreich. Und da, Jakob, gehen wir ganz ans Tabellenende und blicken auf ein Team, das nur acht Punkte hat nach den ersten 13 Spielen und vor allem erst sieben Tore erzielt hat.
Genau, das ist Aji Okser. Die stehen wirklich nicht gut da bisher in dieser Saison. Und das liegt vor allem an der Offensive. Du hast die sieben Tore angesprochen. Den sieben Toren gegenüber stehen auch 15 Expected Goals. Also eine wirklich absurde Unterperformance in der Offensive. Das sind verschossene Elfmeter, das sind vergebene Riesenchancen. Das ist wirklich alles auf einmal. Man muss dazu sagen, auch Okser hat sogar alle der drei Top-Torschützen der letzten Saison verloren im Sommer. Mit Ahmed Traoré, der ausgeliehen war von Bournemouth, jetzt bei Marseille unter Vertrag steht, da aber nicht so wirklich zum Zug kommt. Gaëtan Perrin ist nach Russland gewechselt, zu Krasnodar. Und auch Jubal, einen Innenverteidiger, der aber letzte Saison auch sechs Tore gemacht hat für Okser, ist ebenfalls zu Krasnodar gewechselt. Also da zwei der drei besten Torschützen zu Krasnodar gegangen, der andere ist auch weg. Und das ist dann auch tatsächlich schon der Hauptgrund, warum es in der Offensive nicht so gut läuft, weil der andere sehr wichtige Offensivakteur bei Okser ist Lassin Sinaiyoko, der aber auch in dieser Saison massive Probleme im Abschluss hat. Das kommt bei ihm nicht so ganz überraschend. Der war im Sommer kurzzeitig auch mal bei St. Pauli im Gespräch. Da habe ich mich dann auch etwas näher noch mit ihm befasst. Und das ist auch eher so ein mitspielender Stürmer, der viele Vorlagen gibt. Und jetzt ist aber halt die ganze Last der Offensive irgendwie momentan auf seinen Schultern hat man das Gefühl. Und das bekommt er dann nicht so gut hin, auch wenn er weiterhin eigentlich ein sehr wichtiger Spieler für Okser ist. Und dann wahrscheinlich auch einer der wichtigen Faktoren wäre, wenn man da unten noch mal rauskommen will. Ansonsten ja, sieht es da momentan nicht so gut aus. Aber es kann natürlich auch immer sein, gerade wenn die Zahlen eigentlich besser sind, es ist ja auch tendenziell, sage ich mal schon mal, vielleicht ein Zeichen, dass es auch Pech dabei ist und es auch noch schnell besser werden kann. Dementsprechend ist jetzt auch Trainer Christoph Pellissier noch nicht so komplett unter Druck, zumindest meines Wissens nach. Und ja, man muss mal schauen, ob sich das jetzt in den nächsten Wochen vielleicht ein bisschen wendet. Man muss dazu sagen, es ist ja auch im Tabellenkeller sehr eng in Frankreich. Es gibt viele Clubs, die momentan Probleme haben. Also bis mit einem Sieg könnte Ux ja auch schon auf Platz 15 springen. Das wendet sich jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen relativ schnell. Und wir haben es ja auch bei Metz zum Beispiel gesehen, die ja, als wir die Folge aufgenommen hatten, gerade ihren ersten Sieg gefeiert haben, dann dreimal in Folge gewonnen haben und dann plötzlich im Mittelfeld standen. Jetzt haben sie letztes Wochenende verloren mal wieder und sind jetzt wieder auf Platz 17 abgerutscht. Und es gibt in Frankreich auf jeden Fall genug Vereine, die sich da nicht so schnell rausbewegen werden, glaube ich, aus dem Abstiegskampf. Also so sieben Teams, würde ich mal sagen. Von Platz 11 würde ich eigentlich nur Paris FC rausnehmen, bei denen ich jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarte, dass sie da unten längerfristig drin sein werden. Und dementsprechend ist jetzt auch bei Auxerre noch nicht Alarmstufe rot, auch wenn man momentan das Schlusslicht ist in der Liga.
Das ist interessant, weil so ein bisschen ist es übers Knie gebrochen, aber so leichte Parallelen zu St. Pauli, einem deiner anderen Herzens- und Vereine, kann man da schon erkennen, weil eben sehr lange in der 2. Liga gewesen, dann für ein Jahr hochgekommen, direkt wieder runter. Das ist natürlich das, wo es sich leicht unterscheidet. Aber eben letztlich eigentlich ein Zweitligateam, das jetzt in der 1. Liga angekommen ist, im 1. Jahr ohne Probleme, weitgehend ohne Probleme, den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat und jetzt aber im 2. Jahr Probleme hat und das auch noch mit der Offensive. Also man hat ja auch nach Expected-Goals-Werten nur die drittschlechteste Offensive der Liga. Also es ist jetzt quasi selbst, wenn man alles gemacht hätte. Wäre es noch nicht so arg viel besser, wir gucken mal, ob der Rasenfunk, ja es ist ja dann kein Fluch, sondern ob das Rasenfunk Glück dann zuschlägt, so wie bei Metz damals. Kaum haben wir über sie gesprochen, haben sie nur noch gewonnen. Ich musste ihr erst mal lachen, wenn ich mir die Ergebnisse angeguckt habe. Dann habe ich mir ein gutes Timing. Schauen wir mal, wie es für Oxair ist. Ja ihr 4, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das war wie immer ein wunderbarer Flug über die Ligen Europas und über total interessant, welche Verbindungen. Ich gucke mir ja vorher eure Themen an und dann denke ich mir so, ja gut, schauen wir halt einfach mal, wie es wird. Und dann gibt es immer irgendwelche Querverbindungen, die ich natürlich nicht auf dem Zettel hatte. Aber ihr. Also vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank an Chris McCarthy, an Jakob Haffke, an Christian Bernhardt und an Fabian Pakulat. Danke euch. Ja, sehr gerne.
Danke, Ebenso. Sehr schön.
Aber ich ehrlich gesagt, ich reite euch da eigentlich auch immer ganz gerne rein, mit so einer offenen Verabschiedung. Und ich danke natürlich aber auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und euch würde ich nie in irgendetwas hinein reiten, denn warum auch ihr finanziert den Rasenfunk. Ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorndfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Nico Putzel, bei Krösi, bei Maria, bei Marvin Michel und bei Thomas. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt in den vergangenen Jahren, sondern sie haben sich auch registriert auf rasenfunk.de. Da findet ihr generell auch alle Informationen dazu, wie man uns Geld zukommen lassen kann. Und ansonsten empfehle ich euch sehr, höht euch gerne die Tribüngespräche zum Investoreneinstieg bei der DFL an. Und ansonsten bleibt oder werdet gesund und uns gewogen. Bis bald im Rasenfunk. Ciao. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.